I guess we should probably kick off
there we go I have a microphone how
wonderful
well thank you for all coming this is
frankly kind of terrifying actually nice
nice big room for a new talk which is
the scary place for me personally
um so this is something that I've been
putting together for about the last uh
26 years I think I think about 26 years
of this talk
um or exactly one week depending on how
you internalize it so the easy thing
about doing talks about things you've
done is that you can just show stuff and
people can't really argue with talks
where you just show things that you've
done this is a talk about how I feel
and we're all going to try and feel
something here together and maybe you'll
all disagree with me but I hope you
don't
so I guess most of the people in this
room work in software of some kind and
you know that presiding feeling that
everything is just a bit broken all the
time and everything is just a little bit
wrong and everything hurts a little bit
too much and there's a bit too much
friction and everything doesn't feel
right
and I think
I worked out why
Maybe
um so so my name's David and I spend far
too much time thinking about software
design it's basically kind of my toxic
personality trait
um I have a ridiculous job title I'm the
distinguished engineer comes with a
monocle
um a head of architecture for a company
called New Day Out of London
um I spent about a decade as an
independent consultant but I'm really
here to talk to you about why design is
important
and and really why everything matters
so I'm a programmer and basically you're
going to pry my keyboard out my cold
dead hands regardless of the job title
you stick on top of it
um that said there's not going to be a
lot of code in this talk I really want
you to come on this journey and think
with me and we're going to think about
design now
recently I did a bit of a small viral
tweet I'm used to the screen being here
but it's kind of here
and I was trying to fix an objectively
really terrible code base
and the thing that raised my heckles was
this kind of goddamn awful
organizational pattern and you know this
is kind of ostensibly a.net conference
and I think this is a thing that plagues
so many.net code bases so I sat there
and I rage tweeted into the void
directly I remember thinking like oh God
this is like a damning indictment of the
state of a lot of application design
that this stuff is everywhere these
stupid folders now obviously Twitter
mostly agrees with me otherwise I
wouldn't put it in the conference talk
but the thing that really jumped out to
me of this particularly shitty code base
was how thoughtless it all was like
completely mundanely thoughtless
you know organizing code by
architectural feature is way up up there
on the list of shitty things you can do
to your software with no real meaning
no meaning to it precisely because there
is no answer to the question like why is
this like this why would anyone do this
their software hopefully throughout the
session we're going to try and cover
ways that you can answer the question
why in your software
because that's what design is all about
you know as the joke goes organizing
your code by architectural concept is
like getting a classic car collection
smashing it to pieces and organizing it
by Wheels windscreen wipers and seats it
it ceases to look like anything
certainly not cars when you do that
now so much talk about design in code
always ends up getting dragged back to
the work done in the 90s about design
patterns mostly and this isn't a talk
about design patterns at all
but I want to pay them a little bit of
lip service and a little bit of due
respect
before we get going because perhaps it
might be easy to misinterpret what I'm
about to say as a tirade against design
patterns and about design itself
or a rallying cry against standards but
it really really isn't there
so design patterns what they did is they
originated in the work of a man called
Christopher Alexandra now he was an
actual real-life building architect
originally and he wrote this book called
notes on the synthesis of form which
sounds like a 70s prog metal album I
think mostly and it was consumed by
computer science students around and
throughout the 70s and early 80s and
where where that kind of that process
ended up was Kemp Beckham Ward
Cunningham in the late 80s he started to
writing about pattern languages as as a
thing
now the gang of four book is the book
that everyone will have heard of when
you hear about design patterns so it
came out in 1994 so that's a clear kind
of 15 20 year difference and when all
this work was done and it's probably the
foundational text around design patterns
that you will have seen
and what it really did is it attempted
to lay out a series of structural
creational and behavioral patterns
observed in common software of the era
now one of the core mistakes people make
is they thought this was these people
telling you how to structure your
applications and all they were really
saying is here are some things we have
seen a couple of times
now there's a bunch of noteworthy books
that followed this when you're thinking
about design patterns from people like
Kent Beck you know Small Talk best
practices and patterns I think was the
book he wrote
um and people like Martin Fowler with
the you know the classics like patterns
of Enterprise architecture But
ultimately the intention of all these
books was good but it was kind of
targeting one thing which was to provide
concrete guidance and descriptions of
common solutions to common problems that
have been seen in the market that's all
they were trying to do
and and that's what they really are
they're names to model answers to common
questions and when you give things names
we give things language you Empower them
and you let people talk about them and I
have nothing but respect for the
foundational work that people did to try
and give language around software when
we really had nothing because we're
basically a teenage industry
so this isn't a talk about design
patterns but cool
um patterns try and make categories of
problems look the same
this is about all the things that don't
look the same all the things that are
different all the things that are about
your code
now I suppose I just kind of lament the
fact that most of the talk of design and
software turns into talk about design
patterns because they're kind of the
least interesting part
if design patterns are all about the
parts of the system that are familiar
familiar answers have familiar questions
but with the acceptance of that
we kind of pushed programming languages
to innovate and to make some of those
patterns obsolete over time anyway
so it kind of feels like we forgot to
talk about everything that wasn't
predictable or everything that wasn't
common and because that's where real
design starts where where the talk of
patterns end and you're just left trying
to find form out of something that's
meant to give you function for the rest
of your software
now on the other end of the spectrum
from all the design pattern talk we've
got a large scale architectural
conversations about design and then you
see all The Usual Suspects but if I ask
people to like name application
architectures you would just get like
well enter hexagonal architecture
maybe 12 Factor apps have come up but
that's kind of all people really talk
about
and what they do is they all try and
offer prescriptive rules around the form
of an application how it looks how it's
organized
but I think software design has more
axes than just functional patterns and
kind of large-scale organizational
patterns
I think the most interesting aspects of
design are the ones that affect the way
most programmers interact with the
system and they exist in the Gulf
between those two ends of the spectrum
so it sounds a bit weird but back in the
depths of time
I was a relatively mediocre art student
right and you know and I literally
studied literature and painting and
pottery
and you know this was in the 90s kind of
in high school and you know while I was
specializing in literature and politics
what I really want to be as a programmer
because programming seemed like magic to
me it was like this untangible thing
that no one could really teach at the
time and no one could explain
so for the first half of my career I
really struggled to reconcile this kind
of sense of artistic aesthetic
Sensibility
and Design
you know I started programming in the
mid to late 90s and all of those works
that I previously mentioned they were
kind of the the books that you read if
you were learning about design they were
kind of just the de facto standard now
yeah I did a computer science degree
which I hated and during the first year
of my compsight degree of struggling to
kind of remember how to do maths
like all first-year concise students I
still I stumbled across the works of
Donald news
who had written this book called
literate programming
now this was written in 1984 it was
basically an ancient book by the time I
got to University and computer terms
literally the year I was born so so much
for new ideas
um so newford tried to get Traction in
the space around software design with
the idea that software should be written
by combining what he called a
documentation language with a with a
programming language
and the idea that the union of the two
things would produce a comprehensible
and maintainable code base and that was
kind of his theory now
this is kind of consistent with the rest
of Donald newt's output if you don't
know this is the man that wanted to
write a book so I spent a decade writing
a text editor and then wrote a book so
it's it's no surprise that that's kind
of the place he came from
um and the book was about a fictional
computer and a fictional programming
language
but you know what I I thought
actually if you think about it the
languages that were popular in the 1970s
When Donald knuth was writing about this
stuff
um didn't really look like the languages
we have today they looked more like old
assembly languages and you know kind of
our goals and very very early
programming languages and if you kind of
think about where we are today with
modern programming languages he was kind
of right
in the languages we are we have today
are far more literate they're far more
expressive and um you know they're far
more pliable like an order of magnitude
more pliable because of that so yeah he
was right and languages actually did
Trend more towards literate over time
and a lot of the things he was thinking
around programming languages and
documentation being this kind of Union
of two things that formed the program
I mean you could argue building dsls was
the The Natural Evolution of that kind
of concept so at the core of this idea
really resonated with me that software
is the same as literature
now this was like a bit of a revelation
for me when I was kind of a baby Dev
like it changes it changes the way you
start to see your software when you
think of it like a book
um and a book is only good if we design
the text of the the language in our
program with that in mind if you start
optimizing for a reader and actually
thinking about how your software is
observed
so over the years I come back to this
really really precise definition of what
software really is like when you strip
everything away like what on Earth is
software
software is a constrained form of
communication between programmer and
programmer that describes Concepts or
problems that happens to run on a
machine
almost by mistake the fact that it runs
on a machine is kind of the least
interesting thing about it and the more
you think about it the more it starts to
make sense you spend a much larger
portion of your time of your working day
reading code than you do writing it
and code that exists in a context often
has subtext it has authorial intent much
like any other written language and
actually often like if you think about
the way defects happen in software most
of it is just like a horrible distance
between what the author intended the
software to do what their intention
really was and how they managed to
capture it just like it is in written
language
and you start thinking about it more you
realize actually you know what like all
the the naval gazing conversations about
kind of linting and format is all
actually really about flow and form
and Rhythm like any other writing so
code has a rhythm it has a form just
like writing it has intent it means
something and you use that Rhythm and
that flow in that form to transmit your
intent to say something
your code has intent
do this one if this was in the talk I
did last year and it still stands true
with this topic
um just earn all the copies of clean
code every single one of them we don't
we don't with that anymore it's
aged poorly
um it's not very good
but the worst thing about it
is it has cast this long Shadow over
conversations of design and software to
the point where we think design is what
you name your variables
right like it really it throws out all
meaningful thoughtful discussion and
leaves us in a place where we're you
know we obsess over things like the
solid principles I was having a
conversation with someone the other
night who made the Casual observation
you know the list of substitution
principle only got into a solid just so
it could make a word
right like that's not how you work out
what good designers so thoughtless Dogma
throw it all out
heresy heresy you cry heresy you can
queue up with the pitchforks at the door
and I'll give you a stab on the way out
um you can't say that about clean code I
love writing clean code
I mean there was a point in my career
where I too thought rules around basic
hygiene were enough
but like I say I've been working on this
for 25 years really in the last five
years I've come to Value this idea of
intentionality in the software that we
write above any sense of kind of
syntactic cleanliness
what does that mean
um what it means is every Character
Matters every single thing
I want you to approach the work as if
every single thing you type is important
it's intrinsically part of the work
the white space matters the rhythm of
your code matters naming matters form
matters and function matters
code written with thoughtfulness and
intentionality is code that survives
that humans can comprehend and that's
what makes software fundamentally good
now
thinking of your software as literature
lets you value different ways of
communicating in code
so we can communicate on the macro scale
with organizational patterns and
application architectures
take for example MVC MVC is an
organizational pattern it's a very very
common one it dictates how you split up
your code
and in all of its common implementations
what it really is trying to do is tell
you how to organize your application but
the subtext of that pattern shows you
how an application works and is executed
people are familiar with it and they
understand the flow of control that's
why the MVC pattern was important
you know I I've had a love-hate
relationship with that pattern as an
organizational pattern for quite a long
time because the other unfortunate side
effects you've got to remember
everything is a trade-off
is that the MVC pattern obscures the
intent of the software so all you see
when you look at a code base that's
organizing an MVC pattern is that it's a
website probably
right and every website basically looks
the same and until you start peeling
back the layers you don't really know
what's in there so the form of the
application does not reflect its
function
it reflects the implementation
now
I actually find the micro scale more
interesting because that's the way you
form code on a function to function
method to Method level to Telegraph
intent
now we use form and flow in our code to
increase cohesion as a general
case
now
there's a big horrible block of code
so by way of example when I say use form
and flow to increase cohesion
on this micro scale
I'm going to show you two screenshots of
actually that same code base that I
table flipped about when I got angry at
first now this is a pretty ugly function
it does some HTTP related stuff it's
completely unremarkable but it's really
difficult to read
and it's really difficult to read
because there is no flow or rhythm in
this code at all
you see all that kind of all the white
space what it really does it forces you
to comprehend everything statement by
statement without giving you a message
or a cohesive whole now if I was writing
in English essay I would use paragraphs
and text to capture intent to collate
common Concepts
now code is really just the same now
lines mean something and if you use them
everywhere or nowhere you're removing a
form of expression
now in this incredibly small scale
example you know it kind of does a great
Injustice to the effect of code with
good form
um you know code with great form is like
poetry it leads the eye at the reader it
telegram it telegraphs how you're meant
to read the program because a reader
kind of goes through this head Computing
exercise of following the flow of a
program as written
and all we really did was just delete a
few spaces right we deleted a few spaces
and made it more important and you know
the fluid and the form of your code is
something you use to communicate intent
form is intent it's important it's
design it matters so when I say
everything matters on the smallest
possible level even that was important
to me
foreign
now the more I started thinking about
software through this lens of literature
through this lens of intent the more it
became apparent to me that I was really
reacting to what the inherent complexity
looks like in a lot of modern software
design
and I was kind of craving this clear
communication of well-written prose of
thoughtful code
and that it was really a grander design
problem
now
this sounds ridiculous I've been working
on a sentence recently
sentence who works on sentences
Psychopaths
the complexity of your application
should be at most as complex as the
problem space within the habits and no
greater
every poorly designed piece of software
I had ever seen
exists where the technical solution
dwarfs the scope of the problem
that's bad you're making the world a
worse place you're making things harder
macro and Micro Design are the tools we
have to meet this goal that's kind of
the point
so so many systems just straight out
fail this test you know like they lose
themselves under infrastructure code
under build systems under deployment and
modules and pipelines and reuse
and all these Grand ideas about their
eventual destination Without Really
focusing on what the correct form to
express the solutions of the problem
they have right now is
it buries systems this is like
canonically over design it buries
systems and it makes working in these
kind of code bases like swimming through
treacle
it's like we forgot how to build small
systems
you know we forgot how to build small
things while being Swept Away
fantasizing about building the next Mega
scale social metaverse monstrosity that
was you know pliable for Change and was
going to grow was going to be the next
unicorn we just kind of forgot what made
Small Things beautiful
and the interesting thing about making
about thinking about software design is
even the use of the word design becomes
a little bit contentious because design
means a lot of things to a lot of
different people
designs exist to solve problems so
communicating tent using the form and
their function
it's the same reason that design and art
had a contentious relationship
design is also temporal in nature though
so with many designs you know they only
really make sense in their context in
their place and time
even when you look outside of software
great designs and these are two great
designs everybody kind of knows what
they are through history
um but they're both deeply contextual
you know there are plenty of examples of
products with great period design that
are nonsense now like both of those
things complete nonsense
and a lot of our Legacy expressions of
software design are suffering similar
death in real time in that we have all
these Legacy Notions of what good design
looks like that don't really fit to the
context of the systems that we're
building today
now
there's also this really interesting
observation that taking these two iconic
designs as an example
these are not obsolete these were not
the last of their line right these two
designs
benefited from the fact that design is
entirely iterative as a process
phones didn't cease to exist and vanish
right they were iterated out to touch
phones and mobile phones
walk Commons didn't cease to exist they
became disc ones and iPods
the irony here of course is that these
two designs actually converged over time
because they realized they were solving
the same core problem
which was transmitting audio
it wasn't about music it wasn't making
phone calls
they would they were both transmitting
audio
so in fact the the inherent evolutionary
process that underpins great design
is exactly the same reason people
struggle with disciplines like tdd it's
exactly why when you take say something
like tdd and cast it as a design process
that it's both accurate but not
particularly well understood now I'm
sure you'll have seen probably the
rising tide of people kind of
criticizing tdd on the internet despite
clearly having never practiced it right
and if you've ever done it you read all
these critiques and you're like that
doesn't sound like the thing
that I do
and you realize the commonality in all
of them is they don't iterate on their
design so a lot of people that think tdd
became useless
wrote a test wrote some code did nothing
the fact that you iterate gives your
designs a better quality and the reason
that it's really important and some of
the things I'm absolutely certain of
is that the the the reason the designs
that work through that process become
better because there are whole
categories of things that you only
understand once you can see them and
once you can feel them
so
the folks that think more upfront design
processes yield better results they're
coming from this place where they they
think really hard and they think they
know how something is going to work when
it gets there and they hope they get it
right
the power in an iterative design process
like most real world design is you get
to go again and again and again based on
real people's interaction with the thing
and make the thing better that's built
into the tdd workflow and it helped and
that's why it's great as a design
process right and people miss that
really easily and you know I think
that's just people missing out on an
entire category of signals
now I appreciate the irony here is a lot
of programmers kind of come from this
Trope of not thinking they're
particularly visual people
but it's precisely those visuals that
turn you on and off code when you look
at it you know that ick you feel you
open something up everyone's done this
and you look at it you're like oh God
what is what is this that that is you
responding to visual signal
very very quickly you might not know
what you're responding to but it's it's
learn expressions or patterns you have
seen that give you this kind of gut
feeling of like oh this is going to be
messy I hate this
and that's you responding to design
so if we look at this framing device if
we look at software design as design
it's probably worth us thinking about
the the context that modern software
exists in and how that might change the
way that we do our design it's kind of
worth us reevaluating our organizational
patterns for a modern software context
where we don't build Mainframe software
and we don't build desktop software and
the the programming languages we have
today have made categories of design
completely irrelevant
because design is contextual
now
I'll tell you what
the 10th Generation clean architecture
folks absolutely hate this
most of the things that you think of as
best practice are probably just
overblown structural design patterns
sorry
um and they kind of look as ridiculous
as the kind of Comedy organization by
architectural concept pattern that we
opened up with on that first slide
you know I see a lot of systems designed
these days that have been fragmented
into micro Services especially and who
am I kidding they're not micro Services
what they really really are are like 80
distributed monoliths with a bunch of
messaging glued in between so you can't
see the flow control through your system
right that's what we mostly have
and all of those moving Parts get
extrapolated out and have best practice
of practice practice apply to them and
then what you end up with is these big
monstrous machines where the intent of
the code the thing that it does
is like 15 of the work and how it
orchestrates and does it is all the
things people waste their days doing
you know and the truth is at that point
the overall picture looks fine until you
actually look
and see and I'm going to prove this with
a bit of an example I'm going to show
you an application I was helping work a
team through recently which really like
rammed this home for me now
here's a horrible class diagram you
don't need to be able to read don't
worry it's just the shape of it you're
meant to see
and this was following air quotes a
clean architecture pattern that was
exceptionally prescriptive and
structural but all I see here are the
telltale signs of thoughtlessness
of the fact someone handed someone an
answer as to how to design something and
they just poured it all on like kerosene
and set it on fire
so this system was being recomposed back
into a single logical application
right that was the journey we're on and
it was divided into a huge number of
modules all of which were further sub um
subdivided down into architectural
features
so we had web and we had middle tier and
services and controllers and all sorts
of stuff each part of the application
was its own web application that
depended on linearly a subsequent module
below which contained all the logic like
the stuff where things happened
and then it was all coupled together
with a bunch of shared stuff underneath
and I bet if I said put your hand up in
this room about 60 or 70 of people would
be like yes that's the system that I
maintain I have seen this because we've
all built these it's fine like I'm not
throwing rocks with it but the problem
is
these designs just bring you like total
cognitive overload where to comprehend
this entire thing you have to be able to
comprehend all of the moving Parts in
unison to understand the effects that
change have on this thing
and you know really what we saw is a
huge explosion in the surface area of
the software which leads to an explosion
in the surface area of complexity and it
was all maintained by a single team so
all of this subdivision and pipeline
bloat and component blow didn't actually
give us any other qualities of
scalability
the irony is for all that macro design
when we finished it the the diff on the
left was what the Micro Design looked
like and it was all basically a steaming
pile of repetitive crap but well
organized crap right and everyone would
Zoom back and go oh this is well
designed until you open the code base
so you know it was a classic case of
people focusing on macro structural
design and just yoloing the rest of the
thing
so how do we spot this and fix it
well we did a first round to trim the
complexity down collapsing all the
families of modules where there were
only linear Direct dependencies
into each other we literally cut and
pasted the code back into the thing that
used it
and then rather than having this kind of
complex dependency graph we could just
move the code around freely and then
once we rationalize the code base down
into just one bit for every web app we
realized they were all one logical web
application that we were just shipping
eight times and we just put them all
back together and shipped one
application and deleted something like
37 Bill pipelines and all the all the
stuff around it and all of a sudden the
productivity of the team increased
because they could reason about their
code again
uh the that's what it looked like when
we when we finished we just deleted all
the stuff it was great
build smaller things please
so let's talk about known good designs
so there are obviously certain problem
spaces where there are known good
structural architectural patterns like
the design patterns people weren't wrong
like I say nothing but respect
so the most glaringly obvious example is
kind of rpc's style systems like you
know HTTP apis they often map really
neatly to kind of command query patterns
like we've seen this stuff all the time
but in those systems where you're using
a known good structural pattern to
organize your code
actually the form and the flow of the
application matter even more than ever
because you have to make sure the shape
of the code itself overwhelms the
structural pattern in order for the
application to be comprehensible to the
reader
so I suppose what I'm I'm reaching for
here if I was to reach back to my
literary references it's not just what
you say it's how you say it you know
that's the point
and it matters because when your macro
level design is comfortable
you risk code blindness
so as a reader you start to skim and you
stop seeing the differences and that's
how bugs happen right when the
programmer doesn't comprehend the
complexity of the thing they're looking
at
you know the the intent is missed the
program needs to scream at you what it
does
so in fact one of the the core problems
with known good reference design is that
it's easy to learn a design pattern or
two and decide that everything in
software needs to look the same
right and I've suffered from less
Affliction at various points of my
career like I I screwed up to this was
me
you know maybe you'll recognize some of
these situations I learned about MVC and
thought everything was a controller that
was me
and I first learned about aspect
oriented programming and thought all I
could see was a chain of interceptors
everywhere
um when I was told the controllers were
only ever meant to be about HTTP I
thought everything became an application
service
right so the word service was everywhere
and that's all I could see
um when microservice design first got
popular I thought everything had to be
decomposed
I have made all of these mistakes so
don't feel bad because we all have
and it takes some time to learn honestly
that that uniformity is the opposite of
expressiveness
right it's important that when different
parts of your software do something
different
that their form reflects their function
and they don't look the same as
everything else in your code base
otherwise you'll never know that there's
difference in there
visual variation leads the eye it
encourages reading instead of skimming
language blocks that look identical it's
the same as reading signs you know it's
the same thing
so intentionality
is the opposite of complexity
there's my there's my big flag on the
stage right
stop doing things just because stop
cargo culting design decisions stop just
copying predictable boring application
structures
think
if you don't understand why you're doing
something stop doing it now this seems
like really really obvious stuff but you
look around actual software and
um
not so sure
you know if you can't justify additional
complexity always stop
and unfortunately because so much of
software is context sensitive there are
so many times where blindly applying
design patterns makes software so much
more difficult to reason about and you
just increase the cognitive load of your
system at every leap
a job when we're designing software is
fundamentally a war with complexity
so
when I talk to people about complexity
I'm often a little bit shocked at the
kind of things that people don't
recognize as complexity
so I love this quote there's this great
book that I've been reading recently
from a book called a philosophy of
software design by John K I hope I get
his surname right
um it's really really good and I think
it really gets to the heart of why
complexity is a problem in software I'd
really recommend the book and
specifically its second chapter about
complexity and design I'll put the links
up later but the central theme of the
chapter is this the complexity isn't
caused by a single catastrophic error
tiny paper cuts that accumulate over
time it's kind of like depression and
mental health right it's not a big thing
it's the little things that get you
so from the collection of dependencies
and obscurities and idiosyncrasies at
work that's that's the stuff that you're
being subjected to so ustahoe describes
complexity as the thing that leads to
change amplification High cognitive load
and unknown unknowns
complexity is anything related to the
structure of a software system that
makes it hard to understand and modify
building on that definition I think
intentional thoughtful design is like a
cell for this creeping wave of
almost slept walked complexity into our
applications
now there's this kind of distressing
realization when you reach these lines
of thinking and that's the design
patterns are precisely so popular
because it gives people a way to reach
towards something where the feel is good
they like the answer that they seem to
have reached a definite conclusion a
place to go without having to actually
think about how you got there like
that's their magic trick almost like
here's an easy answer go with it
but once you've seen enough code bases
enough languages you kind of realize
that most of the arbitrary stylistic
qualities of code that people focus on
like tabs versus spaces and brace style
are basically mostly irrelevant like all
that stuff is total noise and instead
there are a couple of like
non-negotiable qualities you look to in
a code base that are far less regimented
than your average like JavaScript style
guide you know good code is code that's
easy for someone with minimal domain
context to read
good code focuses on the developer
experience debuggability and usability
good code where the intent takes up more
visual space than the language syntax
where you highlight what you're doing
not how you're doing it
regardless of language or style or
intent all programmers interact with
code bases in the same way
you know you glance at it to understand
what it does and then you read intently
to understand how it does it
good code regardless of style makes that
that task easy
now and at a meta level
all code is kind of constructed from
this idea of abstractions and
encapsulation like everything we do
glues together those core things and
regardless of programming language and
regardless of ERA this has always been
true
so the programming languages runtimes
and Frameworks which we write higher
level code go through this like enormous
amount of compilation and translation
interpretation to execute but actually
the programming languages themselves
are really just common abstractions over
operating system apis and Hardware
and and really this trend just continues
upwards into the functions you write and
the types that you define and the
classes and files that you create these
are all examples of encapsulation
abstraction
now for the most part we're kind of
blissfully unaware of the huge amount of
complexity living before our
applications
um and actually the nice thing is
the reason these abstractions work is
the benefit of programming against
operating systems and apis rather than
the raw machine is that the the
abstractions provided far outweigh
actually having to know any of that
stuff right the value of learning them
is greater
so as you implement your own software
like sadly it's not a truth that all the
abstractions that you will build will
reduce cognitive load
and this is how we fight complexity it's
often a very subtle process to
understand what doesn't doesn't make
code easier to work with
I'm going to borrow a little bit more
terminology from that book
when I want us to think about an example
of did I just move on yes I did I
skipped a slide sorry
um I wanted to talk about a specific
example which is
um the the file open API in basically
every programming language now the file
open API is like a perfect example of an
abstraction because underneath it
there's a whole extra domain of various
file systems across various operating
systems the entire analogy of files and
folders block access of disks physical
spinning disks SSD all this stuff lives
in the abstractions underneath the file
API which relies on operating systems
and apis which have strapped the
hardware which are a provided
functionality to by device drivers right
you're on a massive stack of complexity
but not one person when they go and open
a file
is concerned with allocating blocks on
an SSD or like the trim operation being
run correctly so we don't damage our
Hardware right it's a good abstraction
it works
um
and if you think about any module in a
piece of software this could be like a
package a class or um or a binary the
you know the interface represents the
complexity so file open offers you an
interface
which represents the complexity that the
module imposes on the program that
consumes it
like simple as that so by the by that
description you can think of some
modules as being deep modules that
represent a lot of complexity downwards
and some modules being shallow where
they only encapsulate a tiny amount of
complexity
now deep modules are good for your
software because they stop you having to
think about a whole category of problems
shallow modules in your own API designs
bleed their concerns out and increase
the cognitive load of the system
so you know it's really important that
when you're making functions like it's
you know the classic clean code thing of
like functions with lots of parameters
are bad why is that or functions with
lots of parameters are bad is because
they believe their complexity out into
the consuming application code they make
your software harder to work with rather
than less difficult to work with
so as much a factor of avoiding the
wrong abstractions you know we really
should be focused on finding the right
ones and it may seem like painfully
obvious advice but abstractions and
generally any other module of code that
you find should contain the problems a
single problem space entirely
now this means that abstractions that
include things like pass-through methods
anyone seen code with loads of
pass-through methods bad code
right and the reason is you've
introduced an abstraction without
actually abstracting anything
and the pass-through method is the smell
or classes that include in their
interface definition the data types that
they operate on internally
you should always be expressing
something that your implementation does
in a higher level higher order
abstraction or again you're not
abstracting anything you're just adding
extra complexities of the calling code
you know in the first example you add
nothing with a pass-through method in
the latter you just leak all the details
so our software is riddled with these
kind of thoughtless abstractions and
poor communication and every time a
design decision like that is made
it decreases the reason the module
exists at all
and it makes the software worse
so anything that adds a large amount of
boilerplate to your code at all is
probably bad right that's the stuff
that's bad
and it's funny when you talk about that
because everybody knows that like that's
the way you feel you get the ick when
you see boilerplate code you open it
you're like oh God what is all this
stuff
but that's the reason it's because
you're being forced to reason with the
implementation of the abstractions that
you're trying to use that's why you feel
that way it's why you feel sad
so
you get to this certain point where you
realize that all talk about design
mostly dissolves into kind of
discussions of dogma and absolutism
and it's because here's an absolute
truth for you ironically
um any design when stretched to its
logical absolute extreme becomes
nonsense
right and I think
you know designing software with
intentions software that survives isn't
always an exercise in compromise and
trade-offs and you work long enough and
you know that
it's why everyone with any experience in
software
and especially software that's been used
by real people or the public pretty much
says it depends to every design
challenge ever posed them
I should have just called this talk it
depends probably
um
you know and and it really does depend
to every design challenge until the
layers of details appeal back
you know in fact a lot of the poor
trade-offs I see in software often
involves people actively not
understanding the sources of complexity
and weird design in the software that
they already have you know doing things
like taking additional dependencies
packages or services for a single use
cases
um you know there's a lot to be said
about the the wonderful lower risk of
just maintaining 30 or 100 lines of code
for something that you could have
otherwise just installed as a package
for free just to avoid the dependency
hell
if you don't need it don't use it
and that's because all dependencies have
surface areas
and actually you know the surface area
of a dependency is an amplica an
amplifying factor to complexity because
if you introduce a dependency somewhere
in your system you could use any part of
its API
it's interesting because it's kind of an
uneasy bed fellow with this idea that
every line of code you write is actually
a burden and is cost right so in in one
sense you're trying to minimize the
amount of code that you write yourself
because that comes with a maintenance
cost but with another I'm standing here
saying oh but watch out just adding
random packages with it because that
increases the complexity and that's a a
perfect example of where this kind of
tension and trade-off really comes in
with real systems
something more constrained with a
smaller surface area though pushes less
complexity into your application
and that's really the thing like the
available potential surface area of your
code
is where the complexity actually flows
from in your application the number of
things you could use
I'll give you a practical example
because I know this is all very
philosophical
um I recently wrote a 200 line of code
program instead of using a static site
generator to build a website because I
didn't believe that the stability of
tools available in the open source
ecosystem with these generators was
stable enough that I wouldn't have to
change it
whereas writing 200 lines of code took
me an hour
I contain that complexity I can change
it it's my maintenance burden but my
gamble is it's less big than the inverse
of having to chase the dependency
upgrade nightmare every time a minor
version changed in the tool I weighed up
the choices and there was less risk to
me
all your designs should really be an
expression of these kinds of trade-offs
and compromises and gentle balance
rather than one single idea layout or
concept dragged to its natural position
of absurdity like everything has to be a
controller we only use things called
services
all classes end with this name
all of that stuff is absurd it's taking
ideas to a place without really
understanding why
and in fact once you stop considering
things as this kind of continual
trade-off
what you realize is instead of rules
around system design you end up with
tests and I don't mean like tests that
we write in software
I mean tests which will evaluate the
qualities of the designs that you make
I want to take you through a couple of
tests I use to evaluate designs and
intentionality and code bases so
hopefully you can look at your choices
from a slightly different perspective
this is my favorite could you do this
with less moving parts
you know a solution with less moving
parts and less systems has less
cognitive load it's easier to
rationalize has less
build dependencies there's just less
stuff and I'm stupid and I got a small
brain none of it fits in give me
something small
there are many places you know in in
most people's ecosystems where
ballooning complexity makes working with
other systems more complex than it
should be you have to realize that
extracting things out comes with
inherent cost
so think about it before you do it
the Golden Rule here is to only break up
systems into individual components when
they need to ship scale or deploy
independently
anything else probably not worth it
is this operable in a production
environment
so software systems that are hard to
observe deploy and manage or automate
slow the pace of change
and this thing is like a multiplication
Factor through your system because if
you slow the pace of change for one team
that you have soon enough you'll be
blocking all the other teams
what what you need to do is build
software that reduces operational
burdens where the design is you know
places where the design is difficult to
configure or deploy
becomes impossible to maintain and
modify which means people stop pushing
changes through it which means the
system rots away
is it easy to change the best quality of
all software
um
software Libs for about five to nine
years unless it's written for some
massive old Mainframe you know it's kind
of a funny observation that most
software that you use you end up in
debates around like picking Frameworks
and how they're going to version and
what the changes are going to be most
software is kept up to date in the
initial part of its development and then
keeping it up to date becomes too
difficult and then it's killed and
Rewritten and replaced with something
else because the context changes
kind of a truism and that was kind of
that part of that foundational
microservice kind of thinking where you
know you're meant to build things that
you can throw away and replace with
other things to do the job minimize the
cost so software that is easy to change
is great you know we should avoid over
design and focus on Simplicity first
so
what I'm really talking about is just
putting the design back into software I
know it sounds silly to say that design
patterns aren't designed but I want
people to you know I want to plead with
you all like desperately just just kind
of think about things before you do them
and there's the whole talk I could have
just come up on stage and said that and
let you all get out of the HotBox
um I want you to think about the design
of your software I want you to think
about the reader I want you to think
about the flow and the form of your
application and what it tells people
I want you to use all the forms of
expression available to you in your code
base to communicate meaning and intent
different problem spaces and different
solutions require different aesthetic
viewpoints we should embrace that
lest we damn ourselves to either
everything is a jumble of components and
HTTP calls great architecture or
everything is an MBC app the the you
know the two architectures
um I don't it doesn't have to be this
way it really doesn't and and where you
use form and designed to Telegraph
intent the work becomes better because
your care shows and I can I see it I can
see it when I open people's code I can
see when they 've given a about it
honestly
like it's obvious
now I was on a podcast a couple of years
back and they asked me this really
horrible question to be put on the spot
on asked which is what advice would you
give to yourself at the start of your
career I was like oh God don't make my
decisions I don't know
um
just spend more time
and it sounds really silly but I know
this is the truth I just all the best
work I've ever done comes from me giving
about 20 extra time to the thing I think
is finished
just sitting there and looking at it and
working out how it makes me feel and
then when I feel something trying to
understand why I feel that way
it sounds like really trite advice but
like never stop asking why is this like
this
why have I made this choice
I want to leave you with a few reading
recommendations as well partially
because I really don't think there are
many good books about this topic at all
I don't think people think about it so
much but there have been a couple
recently so um the one that I quoted
from earlier was a philosophy of
software design by John oosterhaut
um it's brilliant the other one is a
little bit old your code is a crime
scene by Adam Thornhill
he really affected the way I started
thinking about this about a decade ago
with this book where he looks at
software by its other qualities like
change frequency and hot spots and
coupling between people
and recently Mark Seaman put out a book
called code that fits in your head which
touches on a few of these similar kind
of topics of like understanding really
why we make choices in software all
three of those books are far more
exhaustive with examples than any
conference talk could be so if you want
to pour across code examples those are
probably the places to start
support the authors in your community
buy books Keepers and jobs
and uh
yeah ever seen a full talk that could be
described as just it it depends
hi
um you have now I like talking about
design and the use of literature and
intentionality when I talk about
software because you know words mean
things that's the truth words mean
things and the only way we're ever going
to get better at building smaller more
precise more beautiful software is if we
can communicate with each other in
language that means things so I hope
this was interesting
I hope it gave you some new lenses to
look at your designs through I know it's
all very theoretical please don't hate
tweet me I don't want to argue with you
on the internet but follow me on social
media I'd love to chat about it so thank
you all for coming I really really do
appreciate it
[Applause]